welcome back to CBS mornings a new CBS
reports documentary on Congressman
George Santos he of the many
Fabrications will air tonight and as
you're watching because we know you will
keep in mind that sources tell CBS news
that the Securities and Exchange
Commission made inquiries into his
alleged involvement in a quote
fraudulent Ponzi scheme victimizing
hundreds of investors Santos here the
details was a regional director of a
small investment firm Harbor City
capital for about a year before the SEC
shut it down for alleged fraud important
to note that Santos is not named in the
SEC complaint and he has said he was not
aware of any wrongdoing at the firm in
that CBS reports documentary though a
woman says she was a childhood friend of
Santos and she tells our Caitlyn Huey
Burns how the Republican Congressman
used her to try to attract new investors
where is George long before Long Island
voters
I have nothing to hide reporters and
even a Republican senator confronted New
York Congressman George Santos over his
apparent lies I was so outraged I was so
upset Tiffany bagozian who met Santos
when he went by George de volder at this
junior high school in Queens says she
had other reasons to be suspicious in an
interview for a new CBS reports
documentary bogosian told us she and
Santos lost touch until they ran into
each other again three years ago at this
Starbucks guess who I ran into at
Starbucks by then a New York lawyer
bogosian says she told Santos about a
two million dollar settlement she had
just one for a client in response she
says Santos invited them both to dinner
it was this huge room with like one
table in the middle he asked for three
hundred thousand dollar principal
investment and he essentially said the
client was not allowed to know what was
being invested in at all her client
didn't like the sound of it and turned
down Santos's investment pitch and we
now know that that was a Ponzi scheme it
was all fraud yeah in December Santos
apologized for embellishing his resume
after Revelations he never worked for
big investment Banks like Goldman Sachs
or Citigroup as his campaign website had
claimed but one place Santos did work
was an upstart Financial firm called
Harbor City capital where he was
Regional director currently at Harbor
City capital I manage a 1.5 billion
dollar fund right and I know how to
manage it well but after just a year
federal financial Regulators at the SEC
shut down Harbor City capital calling it
a classic Ponzi scheme the SEC complaint
did not name Santos and he has denied
any wrongdoing but after bogosian and
her former client described the dinner
meeting to The Washington Post the SEC
reached out to her about Santa and his
investment pitch it's crazy to me now
thinking back because I mean he's had
these characteristics from So Young when
bogosian says Santos was bullied in
school he was trying to be accepted and
fit in and I think he always felt like
an outcast he started these lies and I
think it just continued and this was the
only way that he knew how so he kind of
felt the need to tell a story to get
accepted into these groups definitely
yes it worked for him then and I think
it worked for him for a long time I mean
it got him into Congress what I want to
know is why
and Tiffany bagozian told us that when
she saw Santos sitting alone on the
house floor she actually felt bad for
him and reached out to him to see how he
was doing she told us that he told her
that these swirling controversies were
all fake news and I'm really excited for
you guys to see this documentary that
was produced by our incredible
investigative unit just amazing amazing
work because we talked to a lot of
people that knew him personally people
that were cheering for him and that were
also duped by him that question of why
is what everybody wants to know why
exactly it occurs to me Caitlyn that he
couldn't get past HR at most companies
but he can get elected to congress well
that is the amazing thing about this
because there's no formal vetting
process for congress you depend on
committees you depend on these party
this party infrastructure and this is
the thing that voters are saying that
they were duped and they're calling for
him to resign and he's resisting those
calls yeah they are calling for him to
resign and uh the title of this
documentary I think puts a pretty good
uh label on it Caitlin thank you very
much it's called campaign of Deceit to
your point David the election of George
Santos and it premieres tonight on eight
at eight Eastern on the CBS News
streaming network and on the CBS News
app